I have a question about your writing
process your books have a lot of
characters that have a lot of potential
of their only books are really short
time I think you know characters like
weasel or the small brown girl Nettles
so I was wondering when you write
characters like these do you have like a
backstory mind we know what happens to
them in the future or are they only in
your head for the brief time that
they're actually in books
I usually always have a backstory of
minor character now it might not be a
really detailed backstory you know I'm
not saying I could but I kind of know
where it came from and how she got to
where she was I don't necessarily know
what happened to her after she parts
from our characters that's another issue
if she comes back to the story and I'll
probably figure out what happened
between then and now you know I
mentioned uh check pants earlier later I
have loved and admired for a long long
time I did a tribute in somewhat he
solves the divine earth with 40 other
writers doing stories in the tradition
of Jack Vance Vance had a gift of making
every character in this book even if
they didn't hear it for a page come to
life as a person you always felt that
this was a real person who had his own
way and will be he didn't know that he
was just a one-page walk-on he thought
the story was about him and I've always
tried to keep answers approach in mind
when I'm doing like my characters you
know because that's that's the way the
real life forms
you know I mean we were all individuals
we all see the world through our own
eyes for me I'm experiencing this event
here as be up on the stage doing a
masterclass and you know you guys are
experienced as well this is the latest
event I went to and after this I get to
have lunch or something like that and
and some of you may be fascinated so
anyway be bored I don't know we're all
staying in their own way and I and I try
to keep that in mind with the characters
and the spear carriers in a book don't
know that their spear carriers they
think it's it's their story they're
living the story of their life so you if
you keep that in mind and usually it
just takes a bunch of someone who
doesn't just say the wine that they need
to say the further plot but they say
some other wine that reflects is that
actually human being there who has their
own agenda as well as furthering the
department that can be enough to bring
them to life at least that's what I try
to do and Vance was the one hundred time
of show Kevin